Matt Reeves, director and co-writer of "The
Batman," may be about to experience his greatest
success to date as the film delivers justice
to the box office.
A character like the Caped Crusader can be
difficult to translate to the screen, and
there are more than a few examples of it not
going well.
However, Reeves has a rich history of elevating
mainstream blockbusters into something more
than the sum of their parts.
Audiences didn't need much convincing to watch
the director's "Planet of the Apes" movies.
The promise of seeing monkeys toting machine
guns on horseback was more than enough to
draw a crowd, but Reeves nonetheless transformed
the material into a sweeping commentary on
the nature of humanity itself.
Though not without its detractors, early reviews
of "The Batman" suggest Reeves has once again
pulled off that trick, with critics praising
its ambitious storytelling and surprising
cast.
Perhaps the most eyebrow-raising choice Reeves
made was his early decision to place Robert
Pattinson under the cowl as the titular hero
himself, a decision he made after watching
the actor's performance in the harrowing Safdie
brothers' crime thriller "Good Time."
But that belief in his star appears to have
paid off, as Pattinson has reflected fondly
on their working relationship in interviews.
Asked by Rotten Tomatoes about Reeves' on-set
instruction, Pattinson reaffirmed his trust
in the director and the rapport they built
while filming "The Batman."
"When you felt it, Matt always felt it ... It
was a kind of an unspoken language that we
developed quite quickly."
The actor also explained that he doesn't always
know what his performances will be like because
he relies on an immersive acting style, telling
Rotten Tomatoes,
"Once you get on to his rhythm, you can kind
of feel — because I'm kind of quite intuitive
about what I'm doing, it's a roll of the dice.
Every take, I don't really have that much
control over it."
Luckily, Matt Reeves' directing style turned
out to be suited for Pattinson's acting techniques,
giving him space to experiment.
"I really like the way Matt directs in a kind
of super minutiae, and does a lot of takes."
Pattinson has been open about the struggles
that came with taking on such a beloved and
iconic character while still hoping to put
a fresh spin on the material.
It's now clear, though, that Reeves always
knew how to help him understand the role.
At one point, after doing over 40 takes for
a scene, Pattinson described himself as nearly,
quote, "having an embolism" and called it
his worst day on set.
However, he also said the director still guided
him through it by showing him what was working
and what wasn't.
It's no surprise that Robert Pattinson has
figured out how to get in tune with a director.
Pattinson spent the decade after his breakthrough
role in "Twilight" acting in a series of projects
with a plethora of celebrated filmmakers,
from David Cronenberg to Claire Denis.
Before "The Batman," Pattinson co-starred
in Christopher Nolan's long-delayed "Tenet"
alongside John David Washington.
In an interview with Entertainment Weekly
from 2020, Nolan said,
"Having worked with Rob, I can say with total
confidence that he can do absolutely anything
he sets his mind to, and I could not be more
excited to see what he does with Batman."
That's high praise coming from the director
of "The Dark Knight," and belies the strong
working relationship the pair developed on
set.
Of course, professional relationships cut
both ways, and it takes a great director with
the ability to use their actors' natural talents
in order to coax out a good performance, even
from a seasoned pro like Pattinson.
Those who have worked with Matt Reeves in
the past say he's exactly that kind of director.
Andy Serkis starred as Caesar the ape in the
recent "Planet of the Apes" trilogy before
being cast as Alfred Pennyworth in "The Batman."
Serkis sang Reeves' praises in an interview
with Collider, saying,
"No matter what he touches, everything is
considered.
It has intention.
It has emotion.
It is powered by great storytelling."
Coming from Serkis, whose previous work has
included everything from the "Lord of the
Rings" trilogy to "Black Panther," that sort
of admiration means a lot.
But Serkis didn't stop there, saying of Reeves,
"He is definitely one of the greats and world-class
directors that we have at the moment."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.